bigham County Idaho Sheriff Craig Roland
told TV station k IDK that the
legislature shouldn't have gotten
involved in creating a statewide system
for collecting and trap tracking rape
kits because as he claims most rape
accusations are false he said quote the
majority of our rapes not to say that we
don't have rapes we do but the majority
of our rapes that are called in are
actually consensual sex the state
lawmaker who introduced the bill
immediately denounced the comments and
soon after the sheriff's absurd comments
lawmakers unanimously approved the new
system and sent the measure to the
governor the bill would require medical
clinics to use rape kits to collect
forensic evidence after a suspected or
alleged sexual assault and then the
clinics would send the evidence for DNA
testing unless the victim requests
otherwise or law enforcement agencies
maybe get the prosecutors approval not
to test the kids as you may know Louis
rape kits contain samples of semen
saliva or blood taken from a victim
during an examination this is then
uploaded to a national database you can
check for a match that may already exist
in the system these comments are so
irresponsible we already have a huge
problem with under reported and
unreported rapes because of the stigma
and shame associated with it and now we
have a sheriff saying most rape
accusations are false a claim that there
is no evidence supporting by the way
he's saying if you report a rape he
would assume that it's false and then
maybe he could be swayed to consider
that the rape app rape report might
actually be real I would love to get a
list of the other crimes Louis from
sheriff Roland where he by default
assumes its most likely false until he
received some kind of contradictory
report yeah it's it quite irresponsible
but we know that this type of thinking
exists all over the country really we
don't normally hear it from someone in
his position according to FBI data the
false rape rate is under two percent
with six to eight percent being unable
to be determined definitively even if
some of those in determinants were false
which obviously that they're not all
false that would bring the number
most to one in ten and don't get me
wrong it is a horrible crime that needs
to be actively prosecuted fake rape
claims need to be prosecuted as crimes
that is very very serious any amount of
false rape is too high but to say that
two to ten percent is most rapes are
false is ludicrous and I also want to
remind you some of those two percent
that are the false rape cases they're
considered false because the accuser at
some point recants or or chooses not to
go forward with with uh with the
prosecution a lot of those you have to
consider are because the victim is just
not emotionally able to go through with
facing the recuse are in court or being
cross-examined by their accusers defense
attorney or whatever so we also have to
remember some of that two percent that
we say are false rape accusations just
because a victim says I want to take
back my claim here we know that some of
those instances are because of the just
horrible nature of being put up on the
stand and cross-examined by someone who
is going to put you in that position
that is horrible yeah that can happen
and I've said like you said let's take
all of these accusations seriously right
and let's make sure that people know
that if they make false accusations that
we really need to throw the book at them
hard Dave really really hard meanwhile
it's estimated two-thirds of rapes and
sexual assault aren't even reported and
we have a sheriff write a law
enforcement official saying most rapes
are false so we don't even need
mandatory rape kits it's just stunning
and this guy certainly does not deserve
to be sheriff of uh isn't did deserve to
be sheriff of insert whatever ridiculous
podunk place you want here uh well well
that in any case let's not go further
down that path because we don't want
upset anybody I'm now I'm i just have
seeing all the comments that might come
in if i were to sort of expand on that
suggestion